currency is another indication of the of
the I guess you would call it the
diffusal power of the federal government
because it used to be the American
dollar yeah but now we've got crypto in
the Constitution states can coin money
yeah well I don't think yeah well right
exactly like hello like has anybody read
this document yeah Santa's bucks yeah
exactly I would invest so hard well you
got to be careful too because I think
both parties would want to go to a
crypto-based system a digital Fiat and
that's always a bad idea oh yeah well
you don't want the federal government
doing it at all you don't
what about Florida coin well I would buy
Florida coin would you all buy Florida
coin yeah I I would local currencies are
extremely important and it's really
really bad that we got rid of them
because what happens now is if Florida
had its own currency that currency can't
leave Florida meaning economic activity
remains within control within Florida so
so do like visiting Canada where you go
in and you trade in
or wait by the local currency yeah and
trade